Moving everything over to one side gives us the quadratic equation x squared
plus 2 x minus 15 equals 0. From here, we can factor to find the x values that
make this equation true. This factors to the quantity x plus 5 times the
quantity x minus 3. And the product of those 2 equals 0. Still, that means to
make this true, x can either equal negative 5 or x can equal positive 3. Now,
let's think about what we're really solving for here. And if we were to do this
graphcially what we'll working on. Well, here we have two polynomial set equal
to another. Just like in the previous problem, we can solve this problem
graphically by setting this side equal to y. And this side equal to y, and then
finding the intersection of those two curves. Let's try it out. You can see here
that we have two points of intersection on this graph between these two curves.
We have one right here, which we see does in fact have an x coordinate of
negative 5. And we have one right here, which, if we follow it down, does in
fact have an x coordinate of positive 3.